what other areas of consumer or social
are you either paying attention to or
excited about that you think people
should or should be aware of the two
base areas I think are really
fascinating in social right now are
calendaring and offline meetups
and then those are kind of connected and
so specifically there's a few companies
like ones called Saturn which is a
calendar designed for teenagers and
another is is called IRL which I just
wrote about today and IRL is an event
discovery platform and calendar which
makes it easy to figure out what's going
on around you set up plans to do it with
the friends or come up with a new plan
like hey let's let's have a Netflix
watching party and then set a soon date
and then figure it out with your friends
in an in-app chat you know it's trying
to make the calendar social in a way
that it hasn't been before
well Saturn is for high school students
and helps them share their classes and
class notes it's basically becoming kind
of a professional linked in esque tool
but for high schoolers and I think both
of those are really fascinating and IRL
actually you know it was about in real
life today pivoted to be in remote life
because we can't really go to any events
like imagine being a startup where you
just help people discover real world
events and then it becomes illegal to go
to real world events like that is a
death knell for most startups but they
were smart to really quickly adapt to
the change lean into it and and pivot to
being all about discovering live streams
of concerts educational classes eSports
tournaments and stuff like that so I
think that's really fascinating is the
idea that a lot of these are gonna just
basically take the social components
that we know exists on other platforms
and just overlay that on the actual
calendar is that the general premise
yeah that's part of it it's about you
taking what is really too deeply bundled
into Facebook and that Facebook has
largely ignored and make it into
something a standalone product that's
really really high utility and really
simple and so yeah with IRL whether it's
about getting you to be able to watch a
live stream with friends or actually
meet up at a coffee shop or go to the
park together
you know it's trying to figure out an
offline availability indicator you know
that's something that we don't have you
have a green dot on all your chat apps
that let people know when you're on the
chat app but you don't have a green
to say hey I'm just home by myself doing
nothing right now I'd love to get dinner
or I'd love to do a workout together or
I'd love to go watch something on
Netflix you know and I think that that's
a really massive area for innovation
which could make us a lot less alone you
know I you know I think a lot of us if
any of you have this college experience
where you know your doors were always
open in the dorm and you could just walk
around and see what other people were up
to and spontaneously make plans as we
grow into adults we put all these walls
and doors between us and it suddenly
becomes a lot tougher to have a
spontaneous social interaction and it
can feel really awkward and kind of
depressing if you reach out director you
a bunch prints hey what are you doing
tonight you want to hang out you want to
go get dinner you want to watch a movie
or something and nobody responds or
everyone's like oh no I'm busy I've got
plans it's really discouraging
and so these apps need to figure out a
way to make that more passive show my
friend that Oh looks like josh is free
so that they could reach out to me if
they wanted rather than me having to do
that work and expend my social capital
and feel awkward when I get rejected
yeah it's super interesting it's like
every couple I know they all manage
their joint life together via Gmail the
G calendar right it's just like hey look
we've got a shared calendar I can see
what you've got going on you can see
what I've got going on and so being able
to bring that to a wider audience than
just a kind of a party of two I think
makes a lot of sense but it also
overlays with what you said kind of a
second component of just offline events
in general what's kind of the thesis
there or what has you excited about that
I'm just excited about the idea that you
know we spend so much of our time
staring at a screen and most of these
apps they monetize by getting you to
stare even deeper into that screen and I
think the next wave of social apps use
Ehnle which is in a product that was
acquired by snapchat snapchat sone snap
map things like IRL the real opportunity
is to say get people offline get them to
have real interactions together in
person those are the things we remember
those are the memories that we cherish
and if you want to add value to
someone's life I think that's the
easiest way to do it but if you can't
meet up offline there's a whole new wave
of apps that are helping people hang out
online and that's around screen sharing
so specifically there's an app called
squad which is
going up right now I think it's at like
number 15 on the AppStore charts all of
a sudden it's rocketing up the charts
after launching last year and basically
it just lets a few people screen share
together so one person can be scrolling
Instagram all the other people comment
or you can be you know debating a tinder
profile and saying oh should I swipe
right or swipe left and it basically
creates the same kind of experience that
many of us had growing up hanging out in
parking lots and basements where you
weren't really doing anything you
weren't like going to a place spending
money doing a like a planned event
you're just Co hanging out and we
haven't had a core layer for that online
and now we finally have one which is
this screen sharing you don't have to be
in the same room to basically just be
hanging out and you don't even have to
be actively talking I think what we had
was this big wave of live-streaming but
most people don't want to be the center
of attention on camera for a sustained
period of time nor do they have enough
to say or do or to show off to actually
be entertaining and so you know things
like a house party made it easier for
people to Alton so that it's more about
group video chat nobody's the center of
attention everyone's just chatting at
once but screen sharing takes it to the
next level where nobody even has to be
on camera you can both just be sharing
your screens not looking at each other's
faces but laughing and joking around
together and occasionally talking and
you know fortnight has similarly created
a role for that for young men and I
think apps like squad which has a female
CEO and amazing woman named Esther
Crawford has an opportunity to do that
more for for young women as well as
everybody yeah it's really interesting
actually the live-streaming component if
you look at many of the largest live
streamers there things like gamers etc
and basically what they would do is
definitely talking about so whereas most
people would try to use live streaming
for shorter periods of time and like hey
let me entertain you these folks who in
the gaming industry would just login
they'd be on for eight to ten hours they
play video games and just like passively
hang out with whoever was there and kind
of talk and and all of those things that
you were doing like the basement you
know years ago they actually ended up
being some of the best live streamers
and built the biggest audiences etc and
so it's unique how maybe the people who
are the best at using these tools
actually use it in a different way than
kind of the majority of folks who you
know got boxed into thinking like this
is just like a short TV screen
I'm actually think this is really
important for mental health I don't know
about you did you ever spend long
periods of time on the phone with your
male friends growing up never I didn't
either
now suddenly boys can sit together on
fortnight for hours just chatting about
their life because they have the
plausible distraction of oh we're
shooting people so weird this is clearly
manly this is there's no affront to my
own masculinity they can feel
comfortable and you know that's I think
that's really productive because a lot
of young men have a lot of feelings they
need to get out and they don't have
other outlets for them and so creating a
channel where they can talk about it
without having be like hey buddy I need
to have like a really hard conversation
with you which might be a bit daunting
instead it could just be like hey we've
been playing for a night for an hour I
was like hey man this girl actually
broke my heart like what do you think I
should do like that's the kind of
conversation that I think we all need to
have more of we need to have more of
those vulnerable real conversations with
our close friends and any product
whether that's a game like for tonight
whether that's a screen sharing app like
like squad or whether it's getting
people together offline they can app
like IRL you know that is a great thing
for destroying loneliness making people
happy or making people feel less
isolated
and that's critical especially now